how are you John Rich I'm doing great
and as you can imagine people here going
crazy I watched the game in Seattle
before I came back on a red-eye have
made I've watched every pitch at the
playoffs and I've been watching the
Astros since their first game in 1962
when I was 10 years old and people here
going crazy and on my flight was packed
with Texans plans many wearing Texas
jerseys and Astro caps and of course it
would have been one of the greatest days
in Houston sports histories if the
Texans had not flown the game in Seattle
well we'll get to that in a second we'll
place that aside as for this Astros team
it just is truly remarkable to see how
these young hitters just keep raking and
how the Dodgers strength has Sal
suddenly now become completely stretched
that bullpen the Astros have gotten into
it and have chewed it up like a like a
chew toy and spit it out what what makes
this team so special in your estimation
Jon alright I gotta admit when Clayton
Kershaw has got a four-run lead in a
three-run lead I thought no way I
thought that Dodgers even though the
Astros have gotten into their bullpen
and roughed it up about they were the
Dodgers were going to win the game and
Astros it they've got really good guys
or that are easy to root for they're
young they're talented they're fearless
and led by Jose Altuve and Carlos Correa
and they have just been very
opportunistic they don't they don't get
down they remain positive and they they
were the best road team in baseball this
year I believe and the road was only
started in the playoffs but they've been
almost invincible other than that one
defeat at home and I think it's a
collective attitude they have from the
hard times many of them experienced
together from being the worst team in
baseball to now the the euphoria of
being one of the two best teams in
baseball that had never won a World
Series game and now on the verge of
winning the city's first championship
since the Rockets won back-to-back at
midnight and then there's the issue of
the manager here okay and AJ Hinch and
what
they issue you take a look at the
Yankees fired their guy and the
Nationals fired their guy and the Red
Sox fired their guy the Mets fired their
guy a bunch of old school managers that
have been doing their best to bring the
analytics world in and then be more of a
millennial arm around the players that
they have in the locker room and
everybody's points to both managing this
world series but pinched in particular
saying we need one of those guys what
has he done in your estimation to get
them one game away first of all if I'm
Dave Roberts and I'd see what happened
to Farrell and Girardi after they lost
to the Astros and I'm boy I'm worried
and I thought it was very unfair what
happened to those guys but when hitch
was hired I'm like who that guy are you
kidding me and JetBlue know the general
manager did a tremendous job and you
know he's at the forefront of analytics
like so many general managers are and he
brought a change in here AJ was already
an analytics guy but analytics are fine
rich you know you still got to play the
game and they brought in good players
and another thing yeah I got to give a
shout-out to Ed wait the former general
measure because as the one that brought
in out to lay in Springer and anybody
who's watched this playoffs in the World
Series sees the contribution of those
two players so he deserves a little
credit but Lou knows done a fabulous job
and hitch right now you know he
everybody here likes him and respects in
the dead anyway because of the way he's
manipulated his roster the way keeps
everybody happy I tried to get
everybody's playing time and and it
seems like just about every move he's
made has been magic except the pulpit
you know both bullpens look like they're
tired worn out and both of them have
been awful and it's just a matter of
survival if you've got to go to the pen
and then one last one for you on this
john mcleaney Houston Chronicle you
mentioned how that the players are easy
to root for for the Astros there's one
in particular out here in Los Angeles
and you Liguria land a lot of folks
coast-to-coast that find it difficult to
root for him after the motion that he
made with his with his fingers towards
his eyes for which he has now been
suspended five games for next year
in regards to you Darvish did you agree
with that suspension John well first of
all register people say they should have
spit at him now suspended him for the
next game and if they had the Union
would appeal and he would have played
anyway so I don't blame Rob Manfred he
said he wanted to get in his pocket will
cost him a lot of money so Carrillo
would have played anyway regardless and
so I got no issues now people in LA all
have issues some people around the
country will have issues it's
interesting rich I'm pretty sure you
won't find anybody in Houston who has an
issue with Rob Manfred some suspension
next season hmm now let's move on to the
Texans John I don't even know where to
start with this one what is the state of
the team as you can tell the state of
the team is they should have beaten the
Seahawks in Seattle where Russell Wilson
is now 37 and six a starter with an
incredible game against an atrocious
past coverage that's two times
deshaun Watson has put them in position
and went on the road and the secondary
and the defense have just blown it with
awful past events and that started in
New England with Brady and now Russell
Wilson the two of them carved them like
pumpkins and they gave up nine touchdown
passes to those two so the teams in good
shape because Watson has been phenomenal
the controversy generated by Bob McNair
you know Bob McNair apologized twice he
met with his players the guy I've known
Bob McNair since 99 never known him one
time to lie never hurt him even even
remotely say anything racist and I hate
to see a guy who has done so much at the
forefront of minority hiring not just
for african-americans but women
Hispanics I could go up and down the
department heads and the VP's here
not to mention 300 million dollars is
given away be defined by one line you
know what I'd hate to be defined by some
of the dumb things I've said throughout
my career and and I feel bad for McNair
he is he's getting he's getting
eviscerated all over the country locally
too and I just he said something said
something stupid you know you say
something stupid you apologize you hope
people can
forgive you and I don't know if people
will but the bottom line it didn't
affect him in the game Bill O'Brien has
done a tremendous job of keeping his
team focused through that controversy
last week through the aftermath of
Hurricane Harvey and course he got a lot
of practice keeping his team focused
when he went to Penn State well let's
just there's two pieces to that let's
choose the first one first in McNair is
that one would think John is that the
player people that know him the best
would be the ones that are around him
the most and that would be the players
the ones with whom they've had either
interpersonal relationships or they
cashes checks and that their reaction
was so visceral was so I heard by it you
have to think that there's more to this
that there's got to be some there there
I mean that's what would you say to that
suppose I would say that the players led
by Dwayne brown lost three point eight
seven million by a contract holdout and
came back last week they they had the
first time anybody knelt in his team's
last two years and then 10 of them
didn't but John's and Joseph's
cornerback told me after game is over is
one-time thing we want to make a point
and and they no truth is I'll bet you I
don't know how many players could get to
tell you anything about what my Bob
McNair is done I'll give you an example
last year after Dwane Brown raised his
fist of New England McNair got with
Dwayne and I think was four others I
wrote this and I can't remember at all
four other African American players who
went to our mayor's african-american and
other minorities and they got to unify
the African American engine minority
community not just african-americans but
minority community with the police
department and I remember afterward
Wayne Brown and everybody praising the
heck out of McNair for stepping up and
doing that and now that was just one
thing and like I said earlier I feel bad
for God says something stupid and then a
lot of people won't camp forgive him and
it's just something that's going to be
part of his legacy and there's nothing
he can do about it doesn't continue to
do the things he's done to help people
and
you believe the the second statement I
know you said you never known him to lie
but you believe the second statement
that he was referring to the league
office as I inmates running the prison
of the league decision-making I have no
idea I know what he said and as I said
before I have never hidden Gary Kubiak
only two people I've ever covered in my
45 years in this business that I've
never caught lying in Kubiak and Bob
McNair and so if he said he was talking
about them and then I believed him a lot
of people don't obviously his players
didn't or they wouldn't they already
tell him in person and and most almost
all of them still decide the deal to
make a statement and I don't know if any
of them continue to do it Jonathan
Joseph said no Dwane Brown didn't say
and so we'll just have to see I do know
this Bill O'Brien will do a good job
keeping the team focused because he's
had enough practice at it well I mean in
that regard to John McClain Houston
Chronicle it really is because I I
couldn't believe that the team played as
well as they did based on everything
that was going on but all that said and
I mentioned this in the previous segment
John 4th and one in New England Bill
O'Brien kicks a field goal fully knowing
who t b12 is has any time left on the
clock and ability to march down the
field for touchdown to win kicks a field
goal there then yesterday three times
has deshaun Watson one of the greatest
playmakers this league's ever seen at
rookie in a game like that handed off
three times some of the play calling at
the ends of the games - needs to be
discussed and I'd love fer to give you
the floor on that so it's been discussed
I asked him two questions about it after
the game he said he blamed himself he
said I got to do a better job of calling
plays and it's so funny because of
Watson throw an interception everybody
killed him O'Brien just getting killed
here it's so funny because of that and
the loss everybody's saying oh he needs
to be fired knee-jerk reactions of
course and bill actually he's the one
that coaches Watson most of the time and
he's one if I was game plan it makes the
calls but yes what I would have done is
I
have had him roll out and I would have
said if a receiver is not wide open
running you know we'll leave it up to
you but we're putting it in your hands
and I'm guessing you know at New England
they didn't really know what they had
now they know what they had they should
have had put the ball in his hands and
he's such a good runner it was third and
four and I'll be I'll say this though
rich you're on the road teams got 149 no
timeouts left and it has to go 80 yards
to score a touchdown no field goal and
your defense blows it again you know I
still blame the defense but O'Brien is
getting a lot of criticism in the last
30 seconds I have with you John any time
in your time in Houston since 76 I mean
we're not we didn't even touch on Chris
Paul being out for a few more weeks now
being part of the Houston Rockets
do you recall a moment like this in time
for Houston Sports well there has never
been a time ever even before my time
that all three professional teams are
creating so much excitement in Houston
and everything is positive even with the
Texans having a losing record people
know they finally have their first
legitimate quarterback since Warren Moon
in 1993 and JJ Watts not even active
right now and that's just an I mean
seriously Houston is is a DIN epicenter
of the sports world right now John so
your perfect guest and friend to have on
the show always appreciate it
gracious my pleasure always thank you
very much they have a great with you -
that's John McLean of the Houston
Chronicle for more Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
the Rich Eisen show app